Most Thermostats in Office Buildings Do Nothing
Thermostat controls in large buildings, such
as many office buildings, don’t usually
do anything.
These placebo controls for large HVAC systems
do nothing but make you think you are adjusting
the temperature.
In some cases, the system even includes white
noise generators to make you think that the
temperature controls are working, when in
fact the heating and cooling systems are controlled
elsewhere.
According to HVAC specialist Richard Dawson,
about 90% of non-secured office thermostats
are placebo controls.
These dummy thermostat controls have been
used as far back as the 1960s as a response
to rising heating costs, which resulted in
landlords specifying very specific allowable
air temperatures for their tenants.
Allowing office workers to individually adjust
temperatures then became inefficacious.
So why install such controls.
Why not just let everybody know the heating
and cooling system is centrally controlled
and not individually adjustable?
This is primarily to cut down on complaints.
As HVACR engineer Joe Olivieri said, “Thermal
Comfort is 90% mental and 10% physical.”
As an example, HVACR worker Greg Perakes says
when a particularly employee called and complained
about being too hot,
“Our solution was to install a pneumatic
thermostat.
We ran the main air line to it inside of an
enclosed I-beam.
Then we just attached a short piece of tubing
to the branch outlet (terminating inside the
I-beam without being attached to any valves,
etc.).
[She] could adjust her own temperature whenever
she felt the need.
Thus enabling her to work more and complain
less.
When she heard the hissing air coming from
inside the I-beam, she felt in control.
We never heard another word about the situation
from her again.
Case solved.”
In another example, Vaughn Langless once installed
air and heating systems in an office building,
only to be inundated with complaints about
the system not working correctly.
“Even though we were sure our system was
working as it should and maintaining space
temperatures to within one or two degrees,
we could never completely satisfy the occupants
of the space.
We mounted a dummy [thermostat] adjacent to
the controlling [thermostat] and gave the
floor manager the key to the stat—now the
occupants could ‘control’ their space
as they desired with the permission of their
manager.
The dummy stat did nothing except to give
the occupants the impression that they had
control of the HVAC system and the psychological
effect of having control of their work environment.
Our service calls disappeared, and to my knowledge,
that system is still set up and working as
it has since 1987.”
Modern HVAC systems use temperature sensors
strategically located that are then used by
a central computer controller that regulates
temperature at each location within a narrow
allowable range.
Herein lies the only real way for most office
workers to adjust temperature in their workspace,
by changing the temperature around the thermistors,
wherever they happen to be located in the
office (often in the air ducts themselves,
though sometimes attached to a wall in a protective
case).
It should be noted though that manipulating
one thermistor by perhaps placing a lamp with
an incandescent bulb right next to it to heat
it or placing an ice pack over it won’t
always work.
The computer system that controls the temperature
will often use readings from several thermistors
in a section of the building to properly regulate
temperature.
So if all the other sensors are reading at
70 degrees Fahrenheit and the one you’re
placing a heat source near is reading 80 degrees,
it will very likely ignore the 80 degree temperature
as a faulty reading.